in the back street of downtown bamako
a booming and illicit trade in gold
young men risked their health using
poisonous chemicals to purify
sixteen thousand dollars worth of gold
the job earns them around two dollars a
day
the gold bar will be sold on the
international market explains this
trader who wants to remain anonymous
he says his gold could be more valuable
than money now that colonel is seized
power from the civilian government
the west african regional body ecomas is
discussing possible sanctions against
mali including
the freezing of financial transactions
and stopping the junta's ability to
withdraw cash from the regional central
bank
this could also affect mali's legal gold
exports which accounts for more than 70
percent of the country's revenues
special advisor says this would
destabilize an already fragile state
we are a landlocked country sanctions
would have a devastating impact
we would start lacking in basic
necessities we would have problems in
cash flow
and be unable to pay our army
to appease widespread calm donation over
the military junta's dismissal of the
civilian
president and prime minister the new
head of state colonel goita
has asked for the opposition m5 civil
society movement to choose
a new prime minister shogel maga is
their candidate
we need to create a patriotic union to
save mali
a union to rebuild our country for the
malian people
despite the turmoil and threat from
armed groups multinational gold mining
companies have expanded operation
in mali over the last decade mali is
africa's fourth
largest exporter of gold
there is so much untapped potential
because of the crisis from gold to oil
to manganese all of it is in the north
the lack of a stable state has allowed
rampant corruption
while it has left many politicians and
businessmen rich
most malians have grown up in poverty
seeing the country's natural wealth and
their say over it
slip away nicholas hawk al jazeera
bamako